we have this from WEAR news ABC3 former
Congressional candidate Rebecca Jones
son arrested in Santa Rosa County this
is a Democrat uh she was like this fake
whistleblower I guess I don't know uh
most of the detail it's been a while but
she ran as a Democrat she is now
accusing what does she what did she say
Rhonda status kidnapped her son
the true story is that let me let me
just uh we'll jump over here
the government of Florida oh the
governor of Florida so here's a tweet
from the Miami Herald 13 year old son of
Rebecca Jones whistleblower who clashed
with the santis arrested over memes
memes here's what community notes added
an incident report released Thursday
afternoon by the Santa Rosa Sheriff's
Office allege that the 13-year-old made
repeated threats to shoot up Holly
Navarre middle school and to stab
students who angered him he also talked
about being on antidepressants that
weren't working so uh that's why he got
arrested right now this Rebecca Jones
woman she's blocked me by the way she is
posting up a storm claiming that here's
here she said two weeks later bringing
us to early today an officer told me the
state issued a warrant for my son's
arrest for digital threats of terrorism
I asked on Whose orders the officer said
it was the state they aren't letting him
come home tonight they kidnapped my son
no it's called arrested lady and now
she's got a whole bunch of Democrats and
leftists being like this is Rondo Santos
he's a fascist assistant the Miami
Herald suggested that he was arrested
for a political statement right yes when
in fact it was terroristic threats
online allegedly yeah but when I looked
this up the Pensacola News Journal was
the one right under it and they're like
that's what she's claiming but let's
talk about what actually happened they
have like a list of his statements that
he made so this is a person Rebecca
Jones she's the one who accused the
sadness of hiding covet numbers yeah
yeah yeah yeah hey these are red flag
laws why why is this lady complaining
her kid got red flag baby and the cops
came and arrested him this is exactly
what Democrats have been asking for why
wasn't she concerned about her son's
death threats because she's she's evil
these people are evil bro it was a
rhetorical question no but there's an
answer because we talk about this so
often when I point out here is a woman
who knows full well what her son did she
is capitalizing off of the fact that her
son is reported to have threatened to
murder classmates and she's using it for
political power
she tweeted before I'm getting out of
Florida or something like this and then
she never did now why would she say such
a thing and then not follow through oh
because they're Liars because she's
lying then when her son gets arrested
because the family is clearly unwell she
says they kidnapped my son and she's got
followers who are eating it up and she
is using this stuff for political gain
well I hope his her son gets a lawyer
that represents his interest in a way
that's better than his mother's doing
yeah
words that he was being homeschooled
school time of his arrest which like to
me sometimes implies that kids are are
being homeschooled for other issues
they're being kept from school I'd like
to just point out Jazz Jennings mother
and that viral video did you see the
viral video where Jazz's mother says she
wakes up jazz in the middle of the night
with the dilator and lubricates it and
says if you don't stick this in I will
so the point here is oh thank God I've
missed that the degree to which these
people are willing to go to cause human
suffering if it empowers them in some
way is terrifying
and right now you have a woman whose son
is in jail for making terroristic
threats so it is so he is charged and
reported and she's using this for
personal gain instead of saying what's
going on between me and my family is
personal and private and I'd like to
keep it that way she rushes to social
media and says help help they kidnapped
my son clearly a lie but she's doing it
for political power and is it that the
son the heavyset person in that picture
no that's the images I think that's
Boogie
got threats she was worried about her
husband and daughter safety didn't send
them out of the stage yeah they'd a flee
it's just all lies it's all lies that's
all they do it makes me sad for her kid
right like if this is how she's
responding my kids being unfairly
kidnapped by the government like if this
kid really does have some sort of issue
apparently his parents are not taking it
as seriously as they should they would
rather point the finger on the Florida
government I guess
I was uh when I when I started making
internet videos in 2006 it was new and I
was like wow I'm becoming a cult leader
this is very dangerous I don't want to
be this I don't want this power this
could easily corrupt me and make me tell
people to do something and destroy the
entire system I can't so I put it down
because it wasn't right but the only
problem is all these other people are
now picking it up and doing it and
they're not ethical you recognize that
people were paying attention to what you
said in a way that you didn't really
want them to they would yell my name
instead of the things I was talking
about right
it's but it's like if I don't do it
someone else is going to do it and I and
I don't trust these other weird like no
offense lady I don't know you Rebecca
but she's weird she's obviously
acknowledge your kid's problem if he was
threatening his classmates acknowledge
it he apparently I saw uh messages where
he said he was placed on antidepressants
but they weren't working
clearly this kid is unwell I feel bad
for him but
man he I can't even read what he said I
don't even think we could pull it up if
I show this YouTube's gonna freak out it
takes me back to the same solution every
time we talk about this kind of stuff is
that don't be a reactionary well I mean
it's okay to talk about crazy stuff that
happens but if you're just constantly
reacting to the bad side you need to
create the good stuff that's the answer
you need to become the famous one you
need to be the one
I'm talking about what these people
think everyone's thinking it right now
and it is a culture War to seize power
well and when you see it and when you
see politicians Embrace a mass shooter
uh you know they talk about a contagion
you know the other folks look at that
and say well I can get similar positive
feedback if I go and murder people these
are dangerous dangerous uh positions for
look at John Brown yeah the story of
John Brown is not a good one I mean look
slavery was wrong no John Brown no one
no one I thought you meant John Brown
something happened just now but no John
Brown history John Brown went to Kansas
as kids and just started murdering
people John Brown walked up to a guy and
shot him in the face I mean look I get
it there are bad things there are evil
things
but it's like
I don't know man
the the their their questions about how
we handle the problems of of Greater
society and there is an interesting
question about was John Brown right to
just walk up to people I I think the
answer is freeing slaves without killing
a bunch of people for the sake of
killing them is probably the right way
to go about things this was before the
war this was before an attempt to end it
what we're seeing here is the next
degree these people who are planning
these things if it if this breaks into
Civil War they're already martyring
these people they stood in the Tennessee
legislature and they all stood there
silently holding up seven fingers
in in some kind of protest symbol like
Hunger Games representing that the
shooter themself was a victim
that is scary yeah yeah and and the
irony is he was a victim of them
oh yeah yeah victim of something for
sure like the parental lack of Parental
oversight you know I mean it took 12
hours for me to even figure out whether
he was a he or she I mean that's how
crazed our media was that they couldn't
tell us with a straight straight wet in
a straight way
the gender the actual gender biologic of
the murderer
the sex yeah whatever the lights
straight up I don't even know what word
I'm supposed to lie what word am I
supposed to say yeah well you could say
one second because everyone is so in
fear of this transgender extremism you
can't even get the who what when and why
reporting for hours well it's it's a
fear of far left terrorism
that's just plain and simple that's what
I've been saying I mean what they talk
about the islamists threatening and
curtailing Free Speech in Europe with by
murdering people who published the wrong
thing who was it recently on scientists
it was Richard Dawkins yeah Dawkins is
being interviewed by I think was it
Pierce where's Morgan this was nuts and
he says can you talk about Solomon
rushing and he goes and he's like well
you don't want to talk about it and then
he's like you are you worried about a
backlash and goes I I don't want to talk
about it I I should have made that clear
yeah yeah and he's like well that's sad
isn't it he's like
that's JK Rowling how she's doing
threats and stuff the point is I can't
imagine her security bills there's got
to be a way to talk about it with
empathy without saying I'm on that side
you don't have to take sides empathy
doesn't mean that you're that you
believe it's right or that you agree
with it it just means you understand and
I think there's a way but it's hard to
empathize with people that are on
psychotropics because they're not it's
hard you know it's hard it's not
impossible but it's hard well they don't
want to sympathize I mean you know
there's no there's no
a person of good faith who isn't
concerned about someone who feels so
crazed about their
you know their body that they would
mutilate it or do these radical
procedures no one no one thinks well
it's good you feel that way and the
question is how how is it we treat it do
we help them or do we in you know
further that extremism or that unhealthy
Matt Walsh broke it down masterfully in
that recent College uh talk he gave
where he asked a person to explain how
they knew they were a woman and the
person just said because other trans
people said they felt similarly to me
and he said well that's how trans people
feel but not women right and the person
did not know or ask how women actually
felt what they were actually saying is
that it's kind of sad the person just
said that they didn't fit in and they
were trying to find a community to fit
into and they did and and she was
getting it or he or she was getting
ratified by her friends said you're
you're a girl and Walsh is like of
course they're going to be nice to you
they're your friends yeah and you know
in my view friends help you not allow
you to kind of yeah go down these paths
that are so if they're terrible in the
end if there was somebody who was
anorexic and you don't tell them and get
them help you're a bad person dude I
used to think if people changed their
name I'd be like what's up fake guy yeah
you're gonna go with a fake name now you
got a costume on like if you were a
beanie I'd be like fake I don't even I
don't even like nothing unless it's pure
real it's fake and then transgender came
along I'm like fake and then but then I
realized that's not the way like Mike
talked to Michael Mouse he's like it's
not it's not that big of a deal you can
have because I'm like what's up with
your fake name and he was like it's not
a dude it's not what you it's not that
big of a thing
and uh I don't know I was smoking a lot
of weed and I was like if it's not
exactly real aligned with God then it is
fake and needs to be flushed but I I
think there's more of a a Middle Road
you know no one's real all the time we
have clothing on you know we're not like
in the buff because that's real
I was I don't see how wearing clothes is
fake yeah protect ourselves from like
the weather but like people wear
lipstick and it's like that's like
what's makeup I was so anti-makeup I was
just anything that's not purely who you
are was pissing me off lipstick is
simulating ovulation isn't it probably
yeah you're like and same with blush is
like the show that you are living in
that reality where I was so anti-fake
was like uh it was anti-social I
couldn't my friends were like I don't
want to be around it I'm like you can't
lie to her you need to tell her that you
slept around with uh and he's like again
I don't want you in my life because I'm
not gonna tell my girlfriend I cheated
on her I'm like you're like an atomic
bomb and people honesty truth yes
despite that like honesty and Truth are
valuable and especially in Friendship
you need to have a an ability to speak
honestly with people right and I think
that's what's the difference between uh
people who feel as though they are not
accepted going online and thinking that
they are getting an honest reaction when
they're actually counting how many likes
they get or how many views their video
gets I think those are uh ways to trick
your brain having a dopamine reaction
but it's very different than if you had
a friend who was like well I want you to
be happy but I'm concerned I want you to
know that like you don't need to contort
yourself to be something you're not like
let let's work on your self-esteem
otherwise I think it's much easier and
sort of less uh terrifying to seek
gratification through social media which
isn't a completely honest form of
friendship you know what I mean
my guess is he has a little bit of
talent there somewhere I disagree
there's somewhere there's something that
he's able you know he would if he was
channeling it directly he might be
successful in a way that would be in my
view appropriate
but there's this crazed approach uh and
you know people are going to be they're
they're going to do their own thing
that's fine but stay away from our kids
don't ask us to ratify it and don't
create an entire public policies around
it I mean we're now someone was telling
me the other day that a huge percentage
of transgendered surgeries
are
um through the military
so what what's happening in our country
that it's you know and the numbers were
such that one could conclude that people
were only joining the military to get
the benefit of the surgery is it just
people in the military or is it also
their dependents because there have been
a couple like high profile cases of
military families well that's a that's a
fair question but the point was the
military is funding and I don't have the
exact number in front of me a
substantial portion of transgender
surgeries
annually in the United States it's wild
I'm glad you brought up Dylan because I
had that same thought earlier you guys
were talking that he's immensely
talented but it's I feel like this
immensely I'll say it because like
that's why he's famous right now is
because it's funny to watch to a lot of
people he dances really well he's a good
mover he has good physical form but he's
been he's gone into this realm of trying
to find clicks that's like I find it
shameful but I mean I'm not whatever you
but it is it's like don't twist things
just for for views yeah you are
incorrect
the videos of Dylan's are spaz stick
like I know it's like he's not rooted
it's not coordinated it's not good
movement it's it's random shaking
convulsing and screaming thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time